For much of the past year, the coronavirus pandemic overshadowed another public health challenge in the United States, that of gun violence. But gun violence did not go away. The nonprofit gun violence archive, which tracks gun deaths and injuries, estimated that guns killed nearly 44,000 Americans in 2020, 24,000 of them by suicide. That's the highest number of annual gun deaths in the past two decades. And in March and April, mass shootings in Atlanta, Boulder, Colorado, and Indianapolis, catapulted gun violence to the forefront of the national conversation yet again.
在过去一年中的大部分时间里，新冠疫情掩盖了美国另一个公共卫生挑战，即枪支暴力。但枪支暴力并未消失。追踪枪支死亡和伤害事件的非营利组织“枪支暴力档案”估计，2020年有近44,000名美国人死于枪支，其中24,000人死于自杀。这是过去二十年来年度枪支死亡人数最高的一年。而在三月和四月，亚特兰大、科罗拉多州博尔德市和印第安纳波利斯发生的群体性枪击事件，再次将枪支暴力推向了全国讨论的最前沿。
What do we know about the causes of gun violence in the United States? Why is it rising now? Who is most at risk of committing gun violence or of being a target? And on this politically polarized issue, can research offer any insight into effective prevention strategies and hope for solutions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological, Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Susan Sorensen, a professor of social policy and health and societies at the University of Pennsylvania,
我们对美国枪支暴力的成因了解多少？为什么现在它在上升？谁最容易实施枪支暴力或成为目标？在这个政治两极分化的问题上，研究能否为有效的预防策略提供任何见解和解决的希望？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学社会政策与健康及社会学教授苏珊·索伦森博士，
where she directs the Ortoner Center on Violence and Abuse. She holds a PhD in clinical psychology and has an interdisciplinary background in epidemiology, sociology, sociology, and psychology. Her research focuses on the epidemiology of the prevention of violence, including gun violence. She has a particular interest in the role guns play in violence against women and in guns as a consumer product. She also served on a panel that developed APA's 2013 report on gun violence prediction, prevention, and policy. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Sorensen. Thank you. I appreciate your interest in this issue and appreciate your invitation to be joining you today.
她在那里指导奥特纳暴力与虐待研究中心。她拥有临床心理学博士学位，并具备流行病学、社会学和心理学方面的跨学科背景。她的研究重点是暴力预防的流行病学，包括枪支暴力。她对枪支在针对女性的暴力中所扮演的角色以及枪支作为消费品的作用特别感兴趣。她还曾参与制定美国心理学会2013年关于枪支暴力预测、预防和政策的报告。感谢您今天加入我们，索伦森博士。谢谢。我很感谢您对这个问题的关注，也感谢您的邀请，让我今天能参与节目。
Great. Well, let's start by talking about mass shootings that have been in the news quite a bit in the past couple of months. But they're responsible for only a small percentage of gun deaths in this country. What are the main drivers of gun deaths in the United States? The most common type of gun death in the United States is a suicide. As you noted, they're about two suicides for every homicide.
太好了。那么，让我们从过去几个月新闻中频繁出现的群体性枪击事件谈起。但它们只占美国枪支死亡人数的一小部分。美国枪支死亡的主要驱动因素是什么？美国最常见的枪支死亡类型是自杀。正如您所指出的，每发生一起他杀，大约就有两起自杀。
But we tend to focus on the criminal uses of guns. And when somebody talks about gun violence, they tend to think of homicides. In 2019, the most recent year for which we have, national data, there are about 14,000 homicides. The next most common type of gun death were shootings by police. And there were 520 that were marked as that. And then the accidents are what we public health people call unintentionals. They're about 486. And then those that they couldn't really determine what the nature of the death was or what the intent was, where about
但我们倾向于关注枪支的犯罪用途。当有人谈论枪支暴力时，他们往往会想到他杀。2019年，即我们拥有全国数据的最近一年，大约发生了14,000起他杀事件。其次最常见的枪支死亡类型是警察开枪，标记为此类的有520起。然后是事故，也就是我们公共卫生界所说的非故意伤害，大约有486起。还有那些无法真正确定死亡性质或意图的，大约有
346. So overwhelmingly, it's an issue of suicide. Well, let's move to gun violence as a public health issue. What exactly does that mean? And why is it important for how we think about prevention? Looking at guns as a public health issue is really important for a couple of reasons. One is it takes a consumer product approach. Like, how do we prevent this? Let's look at the gun itself. Let's look at its design. Let's look at its manufacturer. Let's look how it's advertised. Let's look at how it's distributed, how it's sold.
346起。所以，绝大多数情况下，这是一个自杀问题。那么，让我们转向作为公共卫生问题的枪支暴力。这到底意味着什么？为什么它对我们思考预防措施很重要？将枪支视为一个公共卫生问题非常重要，原因有几个。首先，它采取了一种消费品的方法。比如，我们如何预防这种情况？让我们看看枪支本身。让我们看看它的设计。让我们看看它的制造商。让我们看看它是如何做广告的。让我们看看它是如何分销和销售的。
And then finally, let's look at the purchaser and the user. And almost all of our policies focus on that user component. We spend very little effort and energy looking at what we would call more upstream sorts of issues. And that's in no small part because guns were specifically exempted from the Consumer Product Safety Commission Act of 1976. They were the only consumer product that were treated like that. And so we don't have any safety regulations on guns. To continue this just a bit more, when we talk about a public health approach, we're talking about population. We're talking about policy.
最后，让我们看看购买者和使用者。我们几乎所有的政策都集中在使用者这一环节。我们很少花精力和努力去研究我们所说的更上游的问题。这在很大程度上是因为枪支被明确排除在1976年的《消费品安全委员会法》之外。它们是唯一受到这种待遇的消费品。因此，我们对枪支没有任何安全监管。为了进一步说明，当我们谈论公共卫生方法时，我们谈论的是人口。我们谈论的是政策。
and we're also talking about prevention as to a more criminal justice or after-the-fact approach that focuses on the individuals and on how to treat and intervene after-the-fact. Do you think that the increasing visibility of mass shootings has changed the way people fear gun violence in their everyday life? Yes, definitely. going about our basic activities, it's really important to feel safe. And we've had mass shootings at school, movie theaters, concerts, supermarkets, work, nightclubs, places of worship. These are things that we do every day, just as a regular routine and as a regular matter.
我们谈论的也是预防，而不是一种更偏向刑事司法或事后处理的方法，那种方法侧重于个人以及事后的治疗和干预。您认为群体性枪击事件日益频繁的曝光是否改变了人们在日常生活中对枪支暴力的恐惧感？是的，绝对改变了。在进行基本活动时，感到安全非常重要。我们已经在学校、电影院、音乐会、超市、工作场所、夜总会和礼拜场所发生了群体性枪击事件。这些都是我们每天都在做的事情，就像常规程序和日常事务一样。
And yes, that fear of we're not safe just doing our lives has crept in. And I think it does change people's behavior. We don't have lots of solid research on it. But if you, I mean, this is even cocktail party conversation of what it does. People in the past, I think, would try to avoid certain neighborhoods that they thought were risky or certain circumstances they would think were risky. But this feels different. The mass shootings make it feel random. or that it could happen to anyone.
是的，那种“我们在生活中并不安全”的恐惧感已经悄然滋生。我认为这确实改变了人们的行为。我们没有关于此的大量扎实研究。但如果，我的意思是，这甚至成了鸡尾酒会上的谈资。过去，我认为人们会尽量避开他们认为有风险的社区或某些他们认为有风险的情况。但这感觉不同。群体性枪击事件让一切感觉很随机，或者说它可能发生在任何人身上。
So that lack of control or that lack of ability to protect oneself makes people very, very uneasy. So even though the likelihood of becoming a target of a mass shooting is small, it's the fact that it's so mundane now. It happens anywhere. Yes. Yes, that's well put. So gun sales are at a record high for the second year in a row
因此，那种缺乏控制感或无法保护自己的能力让人们感到非常、非常不安。所以，尽管成为群体性枪击目标可能性很小，但事实是它现在变得如此普遍。它随处可见。是的。是的，说得好。所以枪支销量连续第二年创下历史新高，
and include many first-time gun buyers, according to recent news reports. What drives gun sales among both first-time owners and those who already own guns? And do you think this is a temporary spike, or might this be a continuing upward trend? We'll be able to know if it's an upward trend only after we have a trend and after we have time. I, too, wish I had a crystal ball and could figure that out. But you make a really important point that people have bought a lot of guns. At the beginning of the pandemic, people bought a lot of toilet paper. They also bought a lot of guns.
据最近的新闻报道，其中包括许多首次购枪者。是什么驱动了首次购枪者和已有枪支者购买枪支？您认为这只是暂时的激增，还是可能是一个持续的上升趋势？只有在我们有了趋势并且有了时间之后，我们才能知道这是否是一个上升趋势。我也希望我有一个水晶球能弄清楚这一点。但您提出了一个非常重要的观点，即人们购买了大量的枪支。在疫情初期，人们抢购了大量的卫生纸。他们也购买了大量的枪支。
And that has continued. It's really remarkable that our gun sales used to peak right after mass shootings. And now, nine of the ten high. highest weeks for background checks in the United States are since the pandemic began. And within those 10 weeks, Americans, there have been background checks on nearly as many guns as are sold in an entire year for the highest years that we've ever had guns. So there has been just a surge in gun purchasing. And it's come around mass shootings, such as the Atlanta spa shooting and then the Colorado
这种情况一直持续着。非常引人注目的是，我们的枪支销量过去通常在群体性枪击事件后达到顶峰。而现在，美国背景调查次数最高的十个周里，有九个是在疫情开始之后。在这十周内，美国人进行的背景调查涉及的枪支数量，几乎相当于我们有史以来销量最高年份的全年销量。所以枪支购买确实出现了激增。它围绕着群体性枪击事件，例如亚特兰大水疗中心枪击案，然后是科罗拉多州
supermarket shooting. Sandy Hook is still in there in the top 10. But aside from that, it's been around this COVID when COVID first hit and there was stay-at-home orders, the week of the insurrection in January, around the elections, around political unrest, around the federal election last fall. So it's an indication that there's a lot of. of unrest and fear that people are trying to manage. It's interesting, though, since we're all kind of been locked down for a year, that people feel that they need guns to protect themselves when they're not even going out to potentially dangerous places.
超市枪击案。桑迪胡克小学枪击案仍然在前十名中。但除此之外，它还围绕着新冠疫情，当疫情首次爆发并实施居家令时，一月份国会山骚乱的那一周，围绕选举，围绕政治动荡，围绕去年秋天的联邦选举。所以这表明人们正在试图应对很多动荡和恐惧。不过很有趣的是，既然我们大家都已经被封锁了一年，人们却觉得他们需要枪支来保护自己，即使他们甚至不去那些潜在的危险场所。
It's just puzzling. But I think that's what's going on here. And that's what's been posited as driving gun sales for quite a long time, is it fear, because even while guns, deaths from crime were at low, low rates, low as they had been for 40 years. People were buying more and more guns. I think with that fear is driven in no small part by a lack of confidence in the government and the lack of trust in information sources and the lack of trust of one another. We don't have research on that because this is really hard stuff to research. But that
这令人费解。但我认为这就是正在发生的事情。这也是长期以来被认为是驱动枪支销售的原因，即恐惧，因为即使犯罪导致的枪支死亡率处于低位，处于40年来的最低水平，人们还是在购买越来越多的枪支。我认为这种恐惧在很大程度上是由对政府缺乏信心、对信息来源缺乏信任以及彼此之间缺乏信任所驱动的。我们没有关于此的研究，因为这真的很难研究。但那种
sense of, I don't know what's going to happen. I'm fearful. I need to protect myself. I need to protect my family. And this is a step that people take to try and buttress up that feeling. So you talked about the lack of research, and I know for many years the Centers for Disease control and prevention, didn't fund gun violence research, but that is now beginning to change. How has the lack of research affected the field, and do you think the recent changes will make a difference anytime soon? There's so many important issues that we don't have answers to. The researchers in the field of gun violence have been sort of caught in this catch-22, because, well, what's the answer to that? Oh, you don't have the answer. Well, we can't do
“我不知道会发生什么，我很害怕，我需要保护自己，我需要保护我的家人”的感觉，是人们试图支撑这种安全感所采取的步骤。所以您谈到了缺乏研究，我知道多年来疾病控制与预防中心没有资助枪支暴力研究，但现在情况开始改变了。缺乏研究对该领域产生了什么影响？您认为最近的变化会很快带来改变吗？我们没有答案的重要问题太多了。枪支暴力领域的研究人员一直陷入这种“第22条军规”的困境，因为，嗯，那个问题的答案是什么？哦，你没有答案。好吧，我们不能在没有答案的情况下制定政策，但我们不会资助那些能制定政策的研究。但我认为最令人痛心的是，我们错失了培养下一代研究人员的机会。我们错失了一整批、整整一代能够推动这一领域前进的研究人员，他们本可以再次专注于枪支本身，而不是使用者，不是刑事司法系统和处理流程，而是真正采取那种可能预防和减少枪支死亡的方法。2013年，正如我在介绍中所提到的，您是美国心理学会一个工作组的成员，该工作组撰写了一份关于枪支暴力预测、预防和政策的报告。您撰写了关于在生命周期的各个阶段，即枪支的生命周期，从设计到
policy without the answer, but we're not going to fund the research that we'll do the policy. But I think the most devastating thing has been that we have missed the opportunity to train the next generation of researchers. We have missed an entire cohort, an entire generation of researchers who can carry this field forward, again, focusing on the firearm, not on the user, not on the criminal justice system and the processing, but actually to take that approach that might prevent and reduce gun deaths. In 2013, as I mentioned in my intro, you were part of an APA task force that wrote a report on gun violence, prediction, prevention, and policy. You wrote about policies to counteract gun violence at every level of the lifespan, the gun lifespan, from design to
制造、销售到使用，来对抗枪支暴力的政策。哪些政策是有效的，哪些政策没有达到我们预期的效果？我必须在回答之前说明一个现实，即在这一领域进行研究极其困难，很大程度上是因为我们通常无法进行实验，而实验是研究的黄金标准。你不能随机分配人们拥有或不拥有枪支，然后等着看会发生什么。那将是完全不道德的。而且，我们缺乏获取非常基本信息的途径。在某些情况下，这被联邦法律、机构制定的政策以及有时是州法律所阻碍。所以我们无法在任何持续的基础上获得购买者的数量。
manufacture to sales to use. What are some of the policies that have been effective and what are others that have not been as effective as we might have hoped? I have to preface my response with the reality of it's extremely difficult to do research in this area, in no small part because we can't do experiments generally, which is the gold standard in research. You can't randomly assign people to have a gun or not a gun and then just wait to see what happens. That just would be completely unethical. And also, we lack access to very basic information. And that has been precluded in some cases by federal law, by policies that agencies are put in place, and sometimes by state law. So we can't get information on the number of purchasers on any sort of ongoing basis.
我们获取数据非常困难。正如我所说，有时法律会禁止这样做。所以我们想要的信息在某些数据源中是可以获得的。所以我认为这就是需要做的事情，即获得更多的数据访问权限，以及获得实际研究它的财政资源。但您问的是具体的政策。我只想提供几个想法。
We have a really hard time getting access to data. And like I said, it's sometimes precluded by laws. And so the information that we want can be had in some of those data sources. And so I think that's what needs to be done and to have more access to. to the data as well as the financial resources to actually study it. But you asked about a specific policies. And I'll just offer a couple of ideas.
首先是一个普遍的陈述，那就是美国民众在很多枪支政策上达成了实质性的一致，但国会却不采取行动。如果我们的代议制民主运作得更好，我认为许多枪支政策，例如普遍背景调查，防止不该拥有枪支的人获得枪支，将会得到更好的落实。我想指出的一点是，似乎有效的一项措施是防止施暴者获得枪支。
One is a general statement, and that is that the US population is in substantial agreement around a lot of gun policies, but Congress fails to act. And if our representative democracy were working better, I think a lot of the gun policies, such as universal background checks, keeping guns out of the hands of people who shouldn't have them, would be more in place. One thing I would like to point out as something that appears to be working is keeping guns out of the hands of abusers.
我们有一些证据表明，其中一些法律在减少家庭暴力导致的他杀方面是有效的。这就是“红旗法”的概念，即人们会被标记为有暴力史，因此不能直接走进沃尔玛购买自动步枪。是的。红旗法目前正处于评估过程中，因为它们实施的时间还不长。顺便说一下，没有人能进去购买自动步枪。哦，很高兴知道。谢谢。是的。半自动步枪。是的。但我们已经很久不允许使用自动武器了。也许这也值得一提。1929年的情人节大屠杀，当时有七名男子被枪杀，他们使用的是机关枪。
And we have some evidence that some of those laws are effective in reducing the homicides that are due to domestic violence. So this is the red flag law concept where people will be tagged as having had a history of violence and therefore cannot just walk into Walmarts and buy an automatic rifle. Yeah. And the red flag laws are just in the process of being evaluated because they haven't been in place very long. And just so, you know, nobody can go in and buy an automatic rifle. Oh, good to know. Thank you. Yes. Semi autos. Yeah. But we haven't allowed automatic weapons for quite a while. And maybe that's worth mentioning, too. The Valentine's Day massacre in 1929, there were seven men shot during that, and they were using machine guns.
在那之后不久，我们通过了一项联邦法律，规定不允许平民拥有机关枪。从那以后，就在过去几年里，我们发生了拉斯维加斯的乡村音乐节枪击案，发生了脉冲夜总会枪击案，发生了查尔斯顿教堂枪击案，我们发生了所有这些事件，造成了许多许多人死亡，而国会却未能采取行动。他们在1929年情人节大屠杀后迅速采取了行动，但现在却没有。回到红旗法的问题上。它们在几个州是相对近期才实施的。它们正处于评估过程中。
And shortly after that, we passed a federal law saying we're not going to allow civilians to have machine guns. And since then, just in the past few years, we've had the harvest shooting in Las Vegas, we've had the Pulse Nightclub shooting, we've had the Charleston Church shooting, we've had all of these others, and with many, many deaths, and Congress has failed to act. They have failed to act when they acted very quickly after the 1929 of Valentine's Day massacre. back to the issue of their red flag laws. And they have been relatively recently implemented in several states. And they're in the process of being evaluated.
我们确实知道，其他一些与针对女性的暴力相关的法律，以及作为《针对女性暴力法》和随后的劳滕伯格修正案一部分的法律，都与防止那些被判犯有家庭暴力轻罪的人以及那些受到保护令限制的人获得枪支有关。这是一种在所有50个州都可用的民事补救措施，在某些地方称为限制令，它们有不同的名称。但这些似乎正在产生一些影响。现在，1994年，国会确实颁布了一项为期10年的禁止向平民销售攻击性武器的禁令。我最近看到有报道称，该禁令并没有真正对枪支他杀率产生影响。
And we do know that some of the other laws that are related to violence against women and that we're part of the Violence Against Women Act and the subsequent Lawtonberg Amendment have to do with keeping guns out of the hands of those who have been, convicted of a misdemeanor of domestic violence and those who have been are they subject to a protection from abuse order. It's a civil remedy that's available in all 50 states called a restraining order in some places and they go by different names. But those appear to be having some effect. Now, in 1994, Congress did enact a 10-year ban on the sale of assault weapons to civilians. And what I've been seeing lately is reports that the ban didn't really have an effect on the rate of gun homicide.
这是正确的吗？这是正确的。因为攻击性武器是更多用于群体性枪击事件的枪支类型。如果是所谓的私人群体性枪击事件，例如发生在家庭内部的，当一名男子，通常是男子，杀害他的妻子和孩子或其他家庭成员，然后有时自杀。这些通常是用手枪实施的。就像我们大多数的他杀和大多数的自杀都是用手枪一样。
Is that correct? That's correct. Because the assault weapons are the kinds of guns that are used more in mass, in mass shootings. the more private mass shootings, if you will, such as those that occur in the home, when a man, typically a man, kills his wife and children or other family members, and then sometimes kills himself. Those are most often carried out with handguns. Just like most of our homicides and most of our suicides are with handguns.
所以禁止某种类型的武器，例如那些被称为攻击性武器或攻击步枪的武器，可能会影响一种类型的枪支暴力，例如公共场所的群体性枪击事件，但不一定能影响所有其他类型。您的许多研究都集中在枪支如何影响亲密伴侣暴力，不仅增加了亲密伴侣暴力中的死亡风险，而且作为一种胁迫工具，即使在没有开火的情况下也是如此，您能谈谈那项研究吗？我很乐意。我们在费城做的一些研究
And so banning a certain type of weapon, such as, those that are called assault weapons or assault rifles might affect one type of gun violence, such as the public mass shootings, but not necessarily all of the others. Much of your research has focused on how guns factor into intimate partner violence, not only increasing the risk of death in intimate partner violence, but as a tool of coercion, even when they're not fired, can you talk about that research? I'd be happy to. Some of the research that we did here in Philadelphia
与警察局合作，我们获取了该市整整一年所有的家庭暴力911报警电话。其中大约35,000起是我们所说的亲密伴侣暴力。枪支并不经常被使用，但如果使用了外部武器，我的意思是棍棒、刀、砖块、枪，而不是手、拳头和脚，而是外部武器。
working with the police department and we got all 911 calls for domestic violence for the city in an entire year. And about 35,000 of those were what we called intimate partner violence. Guns weren't used very often, but if there was an external weapon used, And by that, I mean a bat, a knife, a brick, a gun, not hands, fists and feet, but an external weapon.
大约三分之一的情况下，是枪支。涉及到了枪支。当在亲密伴侣暴力事件中使用枪支时，通常是男性对女性使用。大约85%的情况下是男性和女性。另外15%是女性和男性、男性和男性、女性和女性。所以我在这里要使用性别代词，因为研究表明了这一点。当一名男子在警察接到报警的亲密伴侣暴力情况下对一名女子使用枪支时，通常是为了威胁她，为了灌输恐惧。
About a third of the time, it was a gun. A gun was involved. And when a gun is used in an intimate partner violence incident, it's most often a man using it against a woman. In about 85% of the time, it's male and female. The other 15% are female and male, male and male, female and female. And so I am going to use gendered pronouns here because that's what the research indicates. And when a man uses a gun against a woman in an intimate partner violence situation to which police have been called, most often it's to threaten her, to instill fear.
并不是为了射杀她、向她射击或用枪柄殴打她。这在几个方面很重要。首先，在州法律中，在宾夕法尼亚州，就像在许多法律中一样，警察使用可见伤害作为是否值得逮捕的指标。所以当他们去的时候，如果没有可见伤害，他们就不太可能进行逮捕。因此，施暴者能够使用枪支来伤害某人、恐吓某人、恐吓某人，但没有任何特定的后果。此外，那些在事件中使用过枪支的人在警察到达时更有可能已经离开。
it's not to shoot her, shoot at her, or pistol whip her. And that's important for several reasons. One is that in state law, in Pennsylvania, as it is in many laws, police use visible injury as the indicator as to whether or not an arrest is merited. And so when they go and there's no visible injury, read to her. They're less likely to make an arrest. And so the abuser has been able to use a gun to harm someone, to frighten someone, to terrorize someone, but without any particular consequence. Also, those who had used a gun in an incident were more likely to be gone by the time police
所以他们更有可能逃离现场。因此，他们首先就更难被纳入刑事司法系统。而那些以这种方式被使用枪支威胁的女性有着极高的恐惧感，远高于那些被殴打、被刀威胁或类似情况的女性。所以对亲密伴侣使用枪支改变了那种关系的性质。它改变了家庭中的气候和氛围。
arrived. So they were more likely to flee the scene. And so they were harder to bring into the criminal justice system in the first place. And women who had had a gun used against them in this way had astronomically high levels of fear, much higher than those who had been beaten, been beaten, or had a knife used against them or anything like that. So using a gun against an intimate partner changes the nature of that relationship. And it changes the nature of the climate and the atmosphere in the home.
孩子们经常目睹这一点。所以人们会做出评估。就像我们在街上如果有人拿着枪走过来并说，把你的钱给我。我们可能会顺从，我们可能会退缩并说，有没有其他方式我们可以处理这个问题？你知道，我们会给他钱。我们会给他所要求的一切。而如果有人挥舞着紧握的拳头走过来，我们可能会逃跑。我们会逃跑。我们可能会试图反抗。我们可能会试图以某种方式逃脱。
Oftentimes children are witness to this. And so one makes an assessment. assessment. Just like we would if we were in the street and someone approaches to the gun and said, give me your money. We might acquiesce, we might back down and say, is there some other way we can handle this? You know, we'd give him their money. We'd give him whatever he asked for. Whereas if somebody came up with a, you know, a clenched fist, we might run away. We'd run away. We might try to resist. We might try to escape in some way.
但枪支改变了局势的性质。所以我们评估认为存在可信的威胁，它是现实的。然后我们相应地改变我们的行为。这就是家庭中发生的事情。这就是家庭中发生的事情。我的担忧，除了那种经历之外，是枪支的胁迫性使用为持续的虐待和长期的虐待创造了环境，因为她会因为他有枪而害怕离开。而我们知道，当一名女性离开这段关系时，那是她
But a gun just changes the nature of the situation. And so we make an assessment that there's a credible threat, that it's realistic. And then we change our behavior accordingly. And that's what happens in the home. That's what happens in the home. And my concern, in addition to that experience, is that the coercive use of a firearm sets up a context for ongoing abuse and for chronic abuse because she's going to be fearful of leaving because he has a gun. And when we know that when a woman leaves the relationship, that's when
最容易被伴侣谋杀的时候。这种情况有潜在的补救措施吗？我们在联邦层面有一些很好的法律，许多州有所谓的授权立法，基本上反映了这一点，使得那些被判犯有家庭暴力轻罪或有家庭暴力限制令的人不允许购买或拥有枪支或弹药。所以我们在购买部分做得很好，因为如果地方当局拥有的信息被输入到他们的州数据库中，并且上报给联邦政府，因为联邦调查局为大多数州进行背景调查，
she's at highest risk of being murdered by her partner. Are there potential remedies to this situation? We have some good laws in place on the federal level, and many states have what's called enabling legislation that allows, that basically mirrors that, such that those who have been convicted of a misdemeanor of domestic violence or have a domestic violence restraining order against them are not allowed to purchase or to possess either a firearm or ammunition. So we're pretty good at the purchase part because if that information, that localities have is entered into their state database, and that is reported up to the feds because the FBI does background checks for most of the states,
不是全部，但大多数。那么你就可以抓住那些有家庭暴力轻罪记录或家庭暴力限制令的人。不过，我们在拥有部分做得不太好，因为它要求施暴者交出他们拥有的任何枪支。而我们大多只能听信那个人的话。因为我们没有枪支登记册。我们不知道那个人是否有枪。
not all, but most. Then you can catch those people who have those misdemeanor convictions for domestic violence or a domestic violence restraining order. We're not so good, though, about the possession part, because it requires the abuser to relinquish any firearms that they have in their possession. And mostly what we have to do is go on that person's word. Because we don't have a registry of guns. We don't know if that person has guns.
所以我们有时处于一种站不住脚的境地，只能听信施暴者说他们没有枪。我要问你一个政治问题，只是为了让你对此做好准备。国会无法或不愿对枪支和弹药的销售实施限制的一个重要因素是全国步枪协会（NRA）的力量。最近关于NRA内部问题的宣传很多，从财务问题到纽约的一起诉讼，再到NRA负责人韦恩·拉皮埃尔涉嫌滥用资金。在你看来，这些问题是否正在削弱NRA，这是否可能使我们
And so we're put in the sometimes untenable position of simply taking the abuse. loser's word that they don't have guns. I'm going to ask you a political question, just to prep you for this one. One large factor in Congress's inability or unwillingness to enact restrictions on the sale of firearms and ammunition has been the power of the National Rifle Association. And there's been a lot of publicity lately regarding problems within the NRA, from financial issues to a lawsuit in New York, to the alleged misspending of funds by NRA Chief Wayne LaPierre. In your view, are these problems weakening the NRA, and might that make it
在不久的将来更有可能看到关于枪支和弹药的一些真正的政策变化？我相信这些问题确实削弱了NRA。我不认为它削弱了那些NRA成员，或者那些非常坚定地相信NRA几十年来所宣扬的东西的人。NRA过去是，很多人不知道这一点，但他们过去确实是一个运动射击组织。在20世纪80年代，他们进行了一次转型，真正开始为枪支权利敲边鼓，并宣扬政府要接管你的枪支并拿走你的枪支的想法。所以他们创造了一个我从未发现有什么现实基础的叙事，因为在美国，我们的枪支比人口还多。
more likely that we will see some real policy changes regarding guns and ammunition in the near future? These issues, I do believe, have weakened the NRA. I do not believe it has weakened the people who are members of the NRA, or who believe very strongly in what the NRA has purported for several decades. The NRA used to be, and many people don't know this, but they used to be really a sports shooting organization. And in the 1980s, they sort of did a pivot and really got into beating the drum for gun rights and the idea that the government was going to take over your guns and take your guns. And so they've created a narrative that I've never found to have much basis in reality because we have more guns than we have people in the United
假设这是真的，政府确实想来拿走你的枪支。我要把它们拿走。他们甚至怎么能做到呢？他们甚至不知道谁有枪。我们没有枪支登记册。你知道，我们没有一块磁铁能突然吸起特定的金属片并将它们拉出来。这根本不是，这是不可行的。这是做不到的。所以作为一个组织原则，因为你必须记住NRA是一个倡导组织，他们需要像所有倡导组织一样保持资金流入。如果他们一直敲那个鼓，他们会来拿走的，他们会来拿走的。
States. And let's say that that's true, that the government does want to come and get your guns. I'm going to take them away. How could they even do that? They don't even know who has guns. We don't have gun registries. You know, we don't have a magnet that will suddenly pull up specific pieces of metal and pull them out. It's just not, it's not feasible. It's not doable. So as a organizing principle, because you have to remember the NRA is an advocacy organization, and they've needed to keep money coming in, like all advocacy organizations do. And if that kept beating that drum, they're going to come and get it, they're going to come and get it.
这加剧了那种恐惧。它加剧了那种被围困的感觉。但当我们真正审视它时，我甚至不知道这怎么可能发生。那么，关于枪支暴力，我们没有答案的大问题是什么？在我的职业生涯中研究枪支暴力，我将采取不同的策略来回答这个问题，那就是简单地说我们知道得太少了。哦，我希望我能更乐观一些。我希望我能，我应该说我是乐观的，特别是
It heightens that fear. It heightens that sense of being under siege. But when we literally look at it, I don't even know how that could happen. Well, what are the big questions regarding gun violence that we don't have answers to? Having spent my career studying gun violence, I will take a different tact in answering this question, and that is to simply say we know so little. Oh, I wish I could be more optimistic. I wish I could be, I am optimistic, I should say that, particularly,
随着我们将要看到的资金涌入。如果我们能获得数据访问权限，那么我会乐观得多。但我必须，你知道，我认为在解释我们现在所知道的事情时要适当地谦虚和谨慎。它是相对有限的。鉴于此，我的意思是，鉴于我们没有研究，我想你之前提到过，立法者会问，数据在哪里，而你却一无所获。但基于我们所知道的，你认为像你这样的研究人员认为哪些政策变化实际上可以降低这个国家的枪支暴力率？
with the influx of funding that we're going to be seeing. And if we can get the access to data, then I'm far more optimistic. But I have to, you know, be, I think, appropriately modest and cautious in interpreting what we know right now. It's relatively limited. Given that, I mean, given that we don't have the research, I think you mentioned before, that, you know, the legislators will ask, where's the data and you come up empty-handed. But based on what we do know, what are some of the policy changes that really, researchers like you believe could actually lower the rate of gun violence in this country?
为了降低美国的枪支暴力，我认为我们需要一种多方面的方法。我认为我们太专注于寻找那一项或两三项能解决问题的法律。它比那复杂得多。它不仅连接到不仅仅是一个普通的消费品，还连接到人们如何看待自己在世界上的位置以及他们如何看待美国。就像我们发生机动车碰撞时一样。在公共卫生领域，我们开始研究如何减少这些碰撞。好吧，我们没有说，好吧，如果我们能降低速度限制，那么这就能解决一切。我们还有设计问题。所以，你知道，我们现在坐在车里。它们的设计与一两代人成长时所坐的车非常不同。
To lower gun violence in the United States, I think we need a multifaceted approach. I think we focused so much on looking for the one law or the two or three laws that are going to solve it. And it's far more complicated than that. It connects into so much of not just just a regular consumer product, but also so much of how people see themselves in the world and how they see America. It's like when we had motor vehicle crashes. In public health, we started to look, how to reduce those. Well, we didn't say, okay, if we can reduce the speed limit, then that's going to solve everything. We also had design issues. And so, you know, we sit in cars now. They're designed very, very differently than the ones that a generation or two of people grew up in.
我们围绕具体事物有各种各样的法律和特定的干预措施。例如，分级驾驶执照已经大大减少了年轻人的机动车碰撞和死亡。我们过去认为驾驶教育会非常有效。我们对教育有坚定的信念。如果我们只是教育人们，那么他们就会做正确的事情。但我们发现相反，驾驶教育几乎没有效果，有时甚至会产生与我们预期相反的效果，因为它让年轻人更早地坐到了驾驶座上，经验更少，但信心更足，因为，嘿，他们接受过驾驶教育。我们可以通过关于枪支训练的法律。我们可以通过关于枪支登记的法律。
We have all sorts of laws and particular interventions around specific things. For example, the graduated driver's license has substantially reduced motor vehicle crashes and deaths among young people. And we used to think driver's ed is going to be very effective. We have a strong belief in education. If we just educate people, then they'll do the right thing. And we found instead, driver's ed had little to no effect and sometimes the opposite effect of what we wanted because it was getting younger people behind the wheel sooner with less experience, but more confidence because, hey, they had had driver's ed. We can pass laws around gun training. We can pass laws around registration of firearms.
我们可以通过关于防止我们都同意不应该拥有枪支的人获得枪支的法律。我们可以通过关于攻击性武器的法律，这作为一种社会价值声明，即我们认为这种类型的枪支不属于平民。但正是那种全方位的、多方面的方法，给了我们做点什么的机会，给了我们完成点什么的机会。但只看一件事甚至少数几件事是做不到的。我们必须采取全面的方法。好吧，感谢您今天加入我们，索伦森博士。这非常有趣且具有教育意义。
We can pass laws that have to do with keeping guns out of the hands of people who we all agree should not have them. We could pass laws around assault weapons, which it's a value statement as a society that we don't think this type of firearm belongs in the hands of civilians. But it's that panoply, it's that multifaceted approach, which gives us a chance of doing something, which gives us a chance of accomplishing something. But looking at one thing or even a handful of things won't do it. We have to have a comprehensive approach. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Sorensen. This has been very interesting and educational.
我确实希望我们能获得您所需要的数据，以便提出那些或许能让我们作为一个社会减少一点致命性的解决方案。谢谢。不客气。而且我很乐观，因为现在有很多人进入这个领域，因为他们确实意识到这是一个非常、非常紧迫的问题。我们将会有所改变。数据在决策桌上确实有一席之地。谢谢。您可以在美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》的四月/五月刊中阅读更多关于枪支暴力预防研究新资金的信息。只需访问 www.apa.org/monitor。您可以在 speakingofpsychology 或 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
I do hope that we get the data that you need in order to, propose the solutions that will perhaps make us a little bit less lethal as a society. Thank you. You're most welcome. And I am optimistic because there's so many people who are coming into this field right now because they do realize that it is a very, very pressing problem. We will have changes. Data do have a place at the policymaking table. Thank you. You can read more about new funding for research on gun violence prevention in the April-May issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Just go to www.apa.org slash monitor. And you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingofpsychology or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
请，如果可以的话，给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康达扬。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And please, if it's available, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果可以的话，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of psychology at APA.org。即 Speaking of Psychology（连写），at APA.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的音频编辑是 Chris Condayan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。